[Music]
hey youtubers it's Charlie so in my
Walking Dead us video yesterday I
shoulda submit all your questions about
the terminus the finale
Beth everything else so I picked 10 of
them to answer in this video with one
bonus question generally everyone really
just wants to know if barbecue Beth is
gonna be on the menu first things first
though congratulations to chloe Flynn
you are this week's giveaway winner I'll
be reaching out to you and your channel
for details I'll be doing two giveaways
or actually two gift cards will be given
away for the finale video next week I'll
also be doing some season 5 predictions
later this week so be sure to subscribe
to get everything if you're just finding
me for the first time so let's answer
some questions careful for spoilers from
episode 15 and everything up to the
hunters and the comics if you're not
caught up yet but here we go
question number one comes from Guardians
3000 who asks what did Glenn and Terry
used to lure the walkers to the one side
of the tunnel so they just used the
flashlight to cast a shadow on the
opposite wall it was hard to see but the
walkers were attracted to the bright
light in the motion which explains why
in episode nine when Michonne had her
Walker pets and was walking in that big
group of them they didn't turn on her so
the virus ever breaks out be sure to
take these notes down walk slowly
simulating the movements of the walkers
around you and they may not notice you
advice not guaranteed question number
two Gabby chestnut asks do you think
that Maggie and Glenn burning her
picture is foreshadowing yes absolutely
Maggie has actually been one of the
people I think is most likely to die in
the finale for a long time now I already
mentioned how romance is a death
sentence on the show but she is not a
clear thinker Nora's blend and that
impulsiveness is probably going to get
her into some trouble in the finale so
we don't know if the people that took
Beth are hostile or not you know
everyone's getting hunter vibes but even
if they're not hunters they could just
be straight-up villains question number
three max ization asks why are Rick
sands covered in blood in the teaser for
the next episode so that's probably just
a visual teaser from the follow up from
Tony with that candy wrapper on the
railroad tracks Rick well at the very
least end up in a fight with Joe's group
then there's still the wild card of the
people at the terminus there wasn't
anyone at the gate but there was a sign
that said lay down your weapons or you
will be met by force
so there have to be more people there
somewhere Rick does look like most of
his governor beading has healed but he's
still pretty squishy so well I think
he'll have to fight Joe's men you know I
don't think it'll be quite as brutal as
his brawl with the governor and then
there's the added bonus of Daryl being
there to help him out question number
four Dominique lion still asks do you
think we'll learn what happened to Beth
in the finale yes I saw a lot of you
guys commenting as to whether or not
they were going to reveal Beth or save
her for season five we haven't gotten
any answers since she was kidnapped and
there's a laundry list of people that
could have taken her you know from
bandits - Gareth - the hunters I feel
like if they had already revealed what
had happened to her before the finale
things would be like half as stressful
which is a good thing you know from a
writer standpoint I don't know about you
guys but I will go crazy if I don't find
out if she's okay or not
so I'm forced to watch next week which
is a good thing from AMC's perspective
not that I wouldn't watch you know if
everything were reversed even if the
finale weren't as good as last year the
season 3 finale I would still be having
a lot of fun all fairness though the
candlelight vigil for Beth will start
Saturday night question number five pick
a hand asks what the hell with Maggie
why hasn't she expressed more concern
about Beth so I've actually seen a
disturbing lack of concern about Beth
from all the characters except for Daryl
I think there's a couple reasons Maggie
hasn't said anything about it yet first
she probably felt like Beth was in good
company whenever they parted ways at the
prison and two she was forcibly
separated from Glenn so she had no idea
what he was doing whenever they got
split up
she knew Beth got on that bus and got
away and then there's the fact that she
probably is thinking about Beth and just
not saying anything out loud it's not
like she's had a ton of lines since the
season came back but they could be
building Maggie up to a big reveal in
the finale for instance you know we've
established that Maggie is a little
crazy what if something bad happened to
Beth and Maggie just reacts violently if
she's gonna be the one to die Maggie
that is Beth could just be the MacGuffin
that leads to that question number six
Manuel Cortez asks do you think that
Daryl will find out Joe's group is
hunting for Rick before they find him no
I think he'll be totally surprised
whenever they come up on them it makes
for a better ocean
reaction because he'd be stunned that
his friend is still alive and at the
same time Tony would be trying to claim
him with his assault rifle remember how
the other rednecks told Darryl's rabbit
kill he shot first ask questions later
and something tells me the rest of those
guys especially Tony are just like that
and Darryl is just gonna be forced to
choose between the outdoor cats and the
indoor cats you know all this all goes
down let it be said though does anyone
actually think for a minute that Darryl
would not choose his friends over the
Marauders I think a lot of it though
depends on what happened to Beth if
she's okay then Darryl will definitely
come back to the survivors but if she's
not okay
or if she's dead then that could kind of
get thrown into question question number
seven Josh Redgrave asks when the show
ends forever how would you like it to
end so a lot of the time people are
leaving the show because they die and
people are coming on I think the show
should end when the last of the original
cast is alone everyone else from season
one is dead and this last person has to
reform a group somewhere else
they've never hinted that there might be
a cure a real cure that is so by that
logic humanity is just gonna slowly
converge and either die off or hold
their ground indefinitely the numbers
aren't promising so everyone on the
planet will probably be dead inside of
50 years you know unless they cure that
virus I think it ending in a really just
super depressing moment would be
appropriate something that would let you
know that even though that one last
character is still alive with other
people
humanity in general is doomed in the
long run think about it Walking Dead has
been a show of attrition like for every
one new person that comes on the show
two people die question number eight I'm
the donut that's just an awesome name do
you think that Morgan will be involved
in the finale so I think it's still a
little too soon for him to come back
Scott Gimple said that he would reappear
but not this season so next year or
maybe a little bit later but he will
definitely come back at some point I
think that Gareth is the real character
behind terminus for better or worse
though we still don't know if he's a
villain question number nine Joe Kerr
asks do you think that the painting that
Carl found was a painting of Mary the
person that we saw in that last episode
so actually someone on reddit put the
dots together first but yes the person
in the painting looks exactly like Mary
which means that that was probably her
family in that pink room it lends
credence to the fact that she's a little
crazy and we just won't find out till
it's too late
hopefully that mystery meat that she is
serving up isn't what we think it is
question number 10 Maddy Hall asks do
you think that they are eating Beth
she's talking about the grill so this
could actually go down in a number of
ways if they are the hunters and they
are paying homage to the comic books
then they wouldn't be eating Beth
they'd just be eating her leg in the
comics it was Dale who had been bitten
by a walker or whenever that happened
and Beth was just kidnapped she didn't
get bitten so no matter what they're
gonna have to change a few things about
that part of the story I really hope
that they're not hunters but if they are
hunters then I hope that they just have
her tied up somewhere with all of her
limbs attached and one last bonus
question Lauren asks why do you think
the doors of the terminus and the whole
thing weren't really secured so I think
they do have people ready with weapons
in case they need them terminus is in a
nice open area so you would be able to
see Walker's approaching from a long way
away and then there was that sign that
said lay down your weapons or you will
be met by force so I think next week
we'll meet that force so thank you so
much for submitting your questions this
was a lot of fun as always it all goes
down next weekend don't forget I'll be
posting my season 5 predictions later
this week I'll probably be doing a
couple more predictions videos after the
finale to be sure to let me know what
kind of bonus videos do you want to see
me do during the offseason you know do
you want them to look like the Game of
Thrones videos I've been doing for the
last couple of months right now click
here for my review of the episode and
click here for my Lizzy
WTF episode that's actually gonna be a
good one to revisit in the off season
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tonight
high fives
you